you you were speaking about how you're
recording and all these beautiful
musicians y'all were getting
to get to make this music together um
and you have a new album
great songs from stage and screen i love
your voice because i
one of my favorite singers is rosemary
clooney i love that whole style of
singing
um and i love that it's happy music was
that on purpose to do something that was
kind of a little bit more happy and not
so melancholy
yeah well you know we recorded uh most
of this prior to the pandemic in in
london
at abbey road so it's it's oh my god
fortunate that it is
upbeat and and not uh you know we do do
a lot of sad albums as well so luckily
the timing of this worked out because i
don't know that you know more depression
would be what people want right now but
but yeah it turns out you know it's very
upbeat it's every song is
is sort of a a pop version
of um a song from a film
or a broadway show uh and yeah it's just
supposed to be fun and
and upbeat and and uh you know just it's
it's a bubbly record
i mean it's a bubbly record but you're
so gifted and um i was just curious did
you start like young
singing you know what i started with
kelly okay
[Laughter]
well that's why you're amazing seth
yeah yeah you know i you know i was um
my parents always felt that
that music was a an important part of of
the developmental process of the brain
and
and uh so they they they always had
music in the house you know my father
played the guitar and my
my parents signed me up for a a church
choir
when i was a kid if you can believe that
i was that's hilarious
your style of writing but i was actually
a church choir kid as well
yeah yeah i'm sure i'm sure you you were
it
it fit a little better i was i was i was
a little bit of a fish out of water i
was not
i was not uh i probably shouldn't have
been there but but it was
i loved it it was great uh it was great
fun and it was and it was again it was
like it was really
uh helpful for developing the voice and
whatnot and so that
that you know made its way into
local shows local musicals my sister and
i both really
really tried to stay you know somewhere
in that world even on just a local level
yeah it's fun especially when you're a
kid i did all that stuff too um
so is it true you trained as an adult
with the same teachers who train sinatra
because you have a certain flair that is
sinatra like that i
love well they they um it is it was an
elderly couple they they were
lee and sally sweetland they were both
in their late 90s
um and i trained with them for
at least 10 years probably probably
longer than that and they had yeah
you know they had worked with sinatra at
one point i believe
i know they trained streisand at one
point um i i've never
really done my homework and gotten the
gotten the full rundown of
of what their uh what their celebrity
roster is but
um i've gotten fragments and it's very
impressive
[Music]
you